I'm going to release the email about
racial profiling and I understand that
that the penalty comes with potential
outs ting from the Senate
no senator deserves to sit on this
committee or serve in the Senate in my
view if they decide to be a law unto
themselves the document you're talking
about is the nelma been approved through
the committee processes it's been made
public the process worked I learned from
law senator Lee it had already been
worked out that this was going to be
then released to the public the bread
Cavanaugh confirmation hearings are
continuing at this hour
are the questioning continuing senator
Cory Booker just finished his next round
in which he tried to get Brett Kavanaugh
to say that he would refuse himself with
anything dealing with robert muller if
he becomes a Supreme Court justice this
all started this morning and it was
quite a moment as this hearing began
with Senator Booker saying it was his I
am Spartacus moment releasing documents
that he wasn't supposed to release turns
out they were cleared for release
overnight let's bring in our panel
matthew cottan Atty editor-in-chief of
the washington free beacon Susan page
Washington bureau chief at USA Today a
Molly Hemingway senior editor at The
Federalist Matthew this was something I
mean it was just a spectacle to start
this hearing we've seen this really now
three days in a row but it turns out
that didn't need to be a spectacle
that's right nakorn and Senator Cornyn
said while all this was for nothing I'm
not sure that's true what this was for
was Cory Booker's 2020 presidential
campaign and indeed he launched his
fundraising campaign yesterday then it
carried on into the discussion over the
email of course he's not the only member
of this committee who's planning a run
for president his colleague Kamala
Harris is also thinking of running in
2020 and she too has led a line of
questioning that kind of baffled or kept
Kavanagh kind of on his toes this is in
reference to his any conversations he
might have had he says he hadn't done
with the members of the Kazu it's law
firm that had represented Donald Trump
so this is not just Supreme Court
politics it's presidential politics in a
way that I don't think is actual
working out for some of the Democratic
aspirants one of the documents they
released or what we're really fighting
over Susan was about racial profiling
and in it Kavanagh writes an email and
what she says it should be racial
neutral that doesn't seem too
controversial well I guess I agree that
there's politics beyond the Supreme
Court fight itself exhibited in the
committee day not probably not just two
people on that committee who wants to be
present probably most of the Democrats
in the US Senate I think that they ought
to be President I thought it was a
peculiar exchange kind of hard to
explain pop that maybe doesn't rebound
in the way that Senator Cory Booker had
to had hope I do think this is though
the new democratic party we're going to
see from now on the energy in the
Democratic Party the base of the
Democratic Party is demanding a stronger
more disruptive more aggressive action
by the people who want to lead it we've
seen that in the primaries we made that
we've had so far we may see in the
Delaware primary tonight we'll be
watching for that that this is going to
be this is the face of the Democratic
Party now it's going to take on the
Trump administration in a more frontal
or at least show that you are at least
look like you're but fight fight harder
even if you don't have here is your
mission
that's gonna deliver here senator Booker
vowing to continue to release documents
they released those documents after I
had already read further broke their
sham of a rule and if you look at what
I'm doing all day today I continue to
release committee confidential documents
now they're gonna run and maybe try to
ever release say they're okay afterwards
but I will continue throughout this day
release documents that they're trying to
hide from the public
okay he's trying to explain why he was
putting on that that big show after they
had negotiated the release of these
documents overnight there is a process
and Michael II worked with Booker to do
just that now he's saying he's gonna
release more documents to show that he's
not standing up to the rule well and at
this point all of the documents that he
has made requests that they be public
have been made public and I think he
should probably have faith in the
process but that's not what this is
really about of course and I think it's
interesting we've spent the last couple
of weeks being told that
Donald Trump is some sort of unique
narcissist who violates norms and makes
himself the center of attention and that
everyone else in DC is just so wonderful
and yet you watch the hearings like we
have had to watch for the last three
days and you see that in fact this is
not unique behavior to Donald Trump that
there are quite a few people who engage
in this type of behavior and if you want
to know more about Kavanagh you have
been able to see that a little bit I
think Ben Sasse had a really good
discussion about the administrative
state with with cabin on where he
explained a little bit more about his
views there Ted Cruz had a good
conversation about judicial activism
these are probably the issues we should
be concerned about
rather than grandstanding stunts Thom
Tillis of North Carolina now doing the
questioning Susan one of the documents
that got a lot of attention today was an
email about pro-choice op-eds in support
of this justice that he was preparing
and he says I'm not sure that all legal
scholars refer to row as the settled law
this is row v Wade of the land as the
Supreme Court level since court can
always overrule its precedent and three
current justices on the court would do
so that was heralded as this big moment
saying that he would then overrule
precedent and thereby this is how he
would rule he answered the question
saying he was pointing that legal
scholars kind of dealt with it
effectively but that's really where this
goes down to is susan collins republican
from maine and lisa murkowski this was a
crucial point that Senator Collins
pointed out pointed to after she met
with with judge Kavanagh which is if you
think that she wants that she wants to
vote for a justice who believes that roe
v wade a settled law so this is actually
an important point the the the paper
that they released that language Davies
doesn't make it clear where he stands on
this he's pointing out but it does raise
an issue that's been important to her
and Lisa Murkowski the fact is that is
the issue that has the best potential to
give him some trouble as it on his road
to a confirmation although it's not
clear that it's it's done that but it is
does see more on point than the than the
other document that Senator Booker was
putting out and we have yet to hear the
second round of questioning from Kamala
Harris from California she was kind of
had a round of questions asking whether
he had talked to anybody about the
Muller investigation and in a law firm
we may hear from her in a little bit
there she sits next to Cory Booker
getting ready what about that Matthew I
mean it's entually they're looking for
him to recuse himself should something
come before the Supreme Court unlikely
to happen you know Donald Trump has been
very good at nominating judges to the
bench who have track records and
decisions that people can refer to and I
think what we're seeing with judge
Cavanaugh's testimony is the upside and
the downside to that the downside is you
have emails from 15 years ago that
become the hot topic debate and where we
try to read into them different motives
and he's been relatively good at batting
back those accusations the upside is we
have a pretty good idea a very good idea
of how he would rule once he's on the
Supreme Court and that is as an
originalist and a constitutionalist he
has answered a lot of questions with
detail we're gonna leave it here